hey this is Sarah with registered nurse
RN comm and today I'm going to show you
how to find a vein on your patient
before you start an IV starting an IV
takes skill and one of the skills to
help you be successful at it is to find
a good vein that is viable that you're
going to be able to stick first time and
make it easier for the patient and for
yourself so in this video I'm going to
show you how to find veins typically in
males males are a little bit easier to
find veins on especially if they're
healthier because males bands tend to be
superficial and larger compared to a
female females unless I do
cardiovascular exercise or an athlete
their veins are a little bit more
covered with subcutaneous fat so in a
male that you're typically going to see
larger veins so this person I'm using is
male and he's healthy
so his veins are a lot easier to find in
the hospital setting you're probably not
going to have a patient with great veins
like you're about to see here in a
second patients in the hospital are
usually really sick they're dehydrated
so their veins are going to be smaller
and a little bit more difficult to find
so here we go and I'm going to show you
how to do that okay
first you'll want to tell the patient
what you're doing that you're going to
be looking for a vein you really want to
spend a minute or two trying to find a
vein and if you notice his veins you can
see them already without a tourniquet
most people you have to put the
tourniquet on to get these magnets to
pop out so here in a second I'll fit the
tourniquet on but notice even already
see his veins so when you put the
tourniquet on tell them what you're
doing you're gonna put the tourniquet on
and try to put the tourniquet on tight
but not too tight and ask them if it's
too tight but you want it tight enough
so
makes the blood pool in the lower
extremity and already these veins are
starting to collect with blood and
becoming gorge two tips to help engorge
the veins the best you can have the
patient lower their arms so the blood
pools down to the extremity next have
the patient pump their hand this causes
the blood to really pull okay so they
get nice and engorged and compared to
before these veins have became wearing
gorge so I'm going to talk about the
different area that we typically start
an IV on you always like to use the hand
the hand or the arm we very rarely go up
up into the shoulder anything like that
that's usually on really patients your
hard to stick typically the arm is
sufficient enough so first I want to
talk about the antecubital area this is
a si area you may hear in the hospital
setting the nurse say he has an 18-gauge
in his right AC so this is the AC area
that they're talking about typically in
the human the veins are always in the
same spot so everyone should have the
same vein in same areas they can be a
little bit to the left or to the right
but generally they'll be in these areas
right here is the name this is a very
large Great Dane and you can get an 18
gauge in this thing there's a vein right
here in the middle I really like this
thing I normally use it a lot because
it's in patients that I can easily find
I don't see this vein a lot especially
in females I normally see this vein so I
stick that one and then this one this is
another favorite one people really like
to draw blood out of this one - a key
some people are Sears they can see the
vein and they poked it I'm a filler I
have to be able to fill the springiness
of the vein it tells me a lot about how
if the bank rolls if how large it is and
where the placement of it is so if
you're a feeler and
what you need to do is you need to take
your index finger and always fill the
vein veins have a unique feel to them
compared to like if you're filling the
skin it doesn't feel like a vein so if
you're new to starting IVs I really
recommend you practice on yourself with
filling your veins like put a tourniquet
on and just fill your veins get a
feeling for him because once you
understand how they feel you'll know
whether you're feeling abate or not that
was the biggest thing whenever I was a
student I would always say am I feeling
the pain without a bang but now I know
without a doubt because I have it down
so well of halothane feels if it's a
vein
so that's your AC region next region
that people like to stick IVs in is the
forearm typically forearm is from here
to here so that's the forearm area and
there's a lot of veins in the forearm on
this person he has a really really nice
vein right here it's very large a little
bit of a skinnier one right here and
then some more in this area typically
people like to go in this area but I
have seen them on the top of the arm no
a lot of people have superficial veins
from the top of the arm and then on the
back of the arm too there's some if you
have a man and he is hairy
like this you'll want to like shave it
with not the straight leg but just
little clippers and just trim the hair
so whenever you do get your IV you can
tape it down because I've seen a lot of
times where you tape down the IV and the
tape comes
unloose within an hour or two and you
lose your IV so that's always
disheartening when you lose an IV
because you didn't tape it down right so
typically just clip the hairs on a
Malaysian if they have long hair next is
your hand people really love to start
IVs in the hand
because hen does not have a lot of fat
in it so they're really superficial and
you can find them very well so in this
person he has really nice hand pains but
a problem with the hand veins is when
you start an IV these veins like to roll
so let me give you some tips on how to
prevent a rolling vein first of all
whenever you're assessing your veins you
want to make sure it is in a roller how
you can tell if a vein is a roller
you'll take your finger and just sort of
mess with it and whenever you mess with
it do you see how these see how that
vein right there likes to roll side to
side okay what's going to happen if we
didn't use this trick I'm going to show
you if I poked him with a needle I poke
the skin
whenever I poked it it would go to the
side like that okay and then your vet
your needle would go beside of the vein
and set it in it and then it would roll
all you'd miss and you'd have to try all
over so what you would do is you have
the patient hold their hand nice tight
fist and see it keeps really really
tight so whenever I stick him with this
knead with a needle it wouldn't roll
it's less likely to roll so that's
always a tip now if you were starting it
up in the forearm and it was a rolling
thing you could just keep it taut like
that just do your hand out like that and
keep it taut and then poke it with a
needle and it should keep it from
rolling sometimes things are gonna roll
and it's just gonna happen but those are
some little tips and tricks on how to
prevent that and then whenever you're
done of course starting your IV you'll
pop the tarnish off flow fast and then
you're done
so that was just a little bit some of
the tips and tricks I've learned over my
nursing career on how to find a vein
they helped me throughout the year and
and I've increased my success rate with
starting IVs I will be making a video on
how to start IVs so please check that
out and thank you so much for watching
and if you like this video please share
it and subscribe to my youtube channel
and be sure to visit my website register
now starring calm or a bunch of nursing
tips and anything to help with your
nursing school thanks